on the ballot in fact our entire future
is on the ballot
joe biden and democrats up and down the
ballot can change american democracy for
the better
they need your vote it's now easier to
cast a ballot in pennsylvania than ever
before
and it's now more important than ever
before this election
is our chance maybe it may be our last
chance
to restore the soul of our country as
joe biden has said
and to make our lives and to make our
nation
better so let's take on president trump
and the republicans
in harrisburg and in washington so that
we can say no to the backwards and
harmful policies of the past
let's keep fighting together let's vote
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome the west powerton
drummers and steppers
another plant
so
[Music]
so
[Laughter]
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna have a good time tonight
yep
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
to bill and ben
let me know when
not happy
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
so
good
so
[Music]
so
good
so
so
do
[Music]
so
[Laughter]
so
so
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Laughter]
so
so
[Music]
so
so
[Laughter]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
don't believe me just watch
[Music]
don't believe me don't believe me just
lie
don't believe me don't believe me just
right
[Music]
jackson mississippi if we show up we gon
show up
smoother than our first job skipping
the police
[Music]
is
this is how we do it it's friday
[Music]
it feels so good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
been good
then you would know that i gotta get
mine in a big black truck
whatever it is
[Music]
please welcome charlie mack and his
daughter indiana maria
[Music]
thank you thank you good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
my name is charlie mack let me let me
start by saying
what an absolute honor it is for my
daughter india and i to be here today
it's only fitting that we're gathered
here today in the city of brotherly love
we're just 13 days out from the most
important election of our time
when i think about when i think back
about growing up in philadelphia
in the 70s in the 70s and 80s it was a
wonderful time for me
in south philly southwest philly north
philly
alanine and germantown however i spent
my formidable years
in southwest philadelphia where i
learned what it meant to be a man
that's where i met my brothers they were
changing my life forever
dj jazzy jeff and the first prince will
smith
yes give it up for them
they took me from 57 for woodland to
london
to london to australia from australia to
africa and although i traveled the world
there's nothing like home most people
consider me the big brother of our great
city
abruptly love is sicily affection yes
sicily affection
my brothers and sisters we have a chance
to determine where we want to go as a
nation
we have the power to guide our city our
state our country back to decency and
compassion we all
know we need india philadelphia is known
as a great city
so much greatness emanates from
philadelphia and now bestowed upon us is
a great responsibility
to see this election through to the end
13 days
13 days that's all the time we have left
philadelphia and pennsylvania can
control the direction we go
but we have to work we have to work we
have to knock on doors
make phone calls and remind our friends
and family of the importance of this
election
[Music]
then we vote on november 3rd our voices
will be heard we must elect joe biden
and kamala harris as the next president
and vice president of the united states
[Music]
go ahead and go ahead india give a told
india
we must elect joe biden kamala harris is
our next president and vice president
of the united states of america we want
to build a better future for our kids
we need to vote for joe biden and kamala
harris to finally confront the issues
that have held back us for too long that
donald trump has made worse
systematic racism gun violence
gun violence epidemic and the barriers
to educate opportunity
and success for too too many here in
philadelphia across the country
but guess what that's the good part
guess what we have a great time today
because we can vote in pennsylvania and
philadelphia
right now today
[Music]
we don't have to wait until november we
can do it right now right now in person
y'all can vote right now today
now you may have heard otherwise but i
want y'all to know great things happen
here
in philadelphia great things happen here
in philadelphia
[Music]
[Applause]
great things will happen in 13 days and
we're going to make it happen with our
city and the birthplace of america
when we cast our vote for joe biden and
kamala harris
and with that we have the extreme
privilege of introducing
a very great man ladies and gentlemen
please join us in welcoming the pres the
44th president of the united states of
[Music]
america
[Music]
hello philadelphia
man it is good to be back in
pennsylvania
what beautiful weather we got here
little indian summer
you know i know uh the president spent
some time in erie last night and uh
apparently he complained about having to
travel here
and then he cut the event short poor guy
i
i don't feel that way i love coming to
pennsylvania
you guys delivered for me twice and i am
back here tonight to ask you to deliver
the white house for joe biden and kamala
harris
[Music]
i want to thank mr philadelphia charlie
mack
his daughter india marie what an
outstanding
young lady she was those of you who are
fathers and have daughters you know how
that feels when
when you see your daughters just
shining i know a little bit about that
uh and it was great to see
representatives brendan boyle
mary gay scanlon governor tom wolf
attorney general josh shapiro mayor jim
kenney
philadelphia we got 13 days
that's our lucky number right here 13
days
until the most important election of our
lifetimes
you don't have to you don't have to wait
for november third to cast your ballot
you've got two ways to vote right now
number one you can vote early in person
through next tuesday
how many people anybody here voted early
already
[Music]
just if you haven't just go to
iwillvote.com
pa and find out where you can vote early
number two you can vote from home with a
mail-in ballot
just go to iwillvote.com pa
to request your ballot right away and
before you send it back
pennsylvania's got this thing where
you've got to use both envelopes
so you've got to read the directions
carefully to make sure your vote counts
and if you've already voted then you've
got to help your friends and family make
a plan to vote
take them with you if you vote early
or if you vote in person on election day
because
this election requires every single one
of us to do our part
and what we do these next 13 days
will matter for decades to come
now the last time i was in philadelphia
i was at
the constitution center
and i was delivering a speech for the
democratic national convention this year
and i said during that speech i've sat
in the oval office with both of the men
who are running for president and they
are very different people
i explained that i never thought donald
trump
would embrace my vision or continue my
policies
but i did hope for the sake of the
country
that he might show some interest in
taking the job seriously
but it hasn't happened he hasn't shown
any interest in doing the work
or helping anybody but himself and his
friends
or treating the presidency like a
reality show that he can use
to get attention and by the way even
then his tv ratings are down
so you know that upsets
[Music]
but the thing is this is not a reality
show this is reality
and the rest of us have had to live with
the consequences of him
proving himself incapable of taking the
job seriously
at least 220 000 americans
have died more than 100 000
small businesses have closed
millions of jobs are gone
our proud reputation around the world
is in tatters
presidents up for re-election usually
ask if the country is better off than it
was four years ago
i'll tell you one thing four years ago
you'd be tailgating here at the link
instead of watching a speech from your
cars
the only people truly better off than
they were four years ago
are the billionaires who got his tax
cuts
right now as we speak trump won't even
extend relief to the millions of
families who are having trouble paying
the rent
or putting food on the table because of
this pandemic
but he's been doing all right by himself
as it turns out this was just reported
in the last 48 hours
we know that he continues to do business
with china
because he's got a secret chinese bank
account
how is that possible how is that
possible
a secret chinese bank account listen can
you imagine if i had a secret chinese
bank account
when i was running for reelection
you think you think my you think fox
news might have been a little concerned
about that
they would have called me beijing barry
it is not a great idea
to have a president who owes a bunch of
money
to people overseas that's that's not a
good idea
i mean of the taxes donald trump pays
he may be sending more to foreign
governments than he pays
in the united states his first year in
the white house he only paid 750
dollars in federal income taxes listen
my first job was at a baskin robbins
when i was 15 years old
i think i might have paid more taxes
that year working at a
dispensing ice cream
how is that possible how many
people here paid less than that
it's possible just possible now that if
if you are living high on the hog and
you only pay 750
uh dollars in taxes that maybe just
maybe
he might not know what working people
are going through here in pennsylvania
we cannot afford four more years of this
philadelphia
but the good news is right now you can
choose change right now
you can vote for my friend joe biden
and his running mate kamala harris as
the next
president and vice president of the
united states of america
now joe joe's no stranger to he he's a
native son
scrappy kid from scranton you know him
and you know he knows you but let me
let me tell you how i came to know him
and and how i came to love him
12 years ago when i chose
when i chose joe biden as vice president
as
as my vice presidential running bank
i didn't know joe all that well we had
served in the senate together but we
weren't
super close he and i came from different
places
we came from different generations
but i came to admire joe
as a man who has learned early on
to treat everybody he meets with dignity
and respect
living by the words his parents taught
him no one's better than you joe but
you're better than nobody
and that empathy that decency
that belief that everybody counts that's
who joe is
that's who he'll be and i can tell you
the presidency doesn't change who you
are
it reveals who you are and joe has shown
himself to be a friend of working people
for eight years joe was the last one in
the room when i faced a big decision
he made me a better president
and he's got the character and
experience to make us a better country
and he and kamala are going to be in the
fight not for themselves
but for every single one of us
look i get that this president wants
full credit for the economy he inherited
and zero blame for the pandemic that he
ignored
but you know what the job doesn't work
that way
tweeting at the television doesn't fix
things
making stuff up doesn't make people's
lives better
you've got to have a plan you've got to
put in the work
and along with the experience to get
things done joe biden has concrete plans
and policies
that will turn our vision of a better
fairer stronger country
into a reality
we literally left this white house a
pandemic
playbook that would have shown them how
to respond
before the virus reached our shores
they probably used it to i don't know
prop up a wobbly table somewhere we
don't know where that playbook went
eight months into this pandemic cases
are rising again across this country
donald trump isn't suddenly going to
protect all of us
he can't even take the basic steps to
protect himself
just last night he complained up in erie
that the pandemic made him go back to
work i'm quoting here
he was he was upset that the pandemics
made him go back to work
if he'd actually been working the whole
time it never would have gotten this bad
so look here's the truth i want to be
honest here
this pandemic would have been
challenging for any president
but this idea that somehow this white
house
has done anything but completely screw
this up
is just not true i'll give you a
very specific example korea identified
its first case
at the same time that the united states
did
at the same time their per capita death
toll
is just 1.3 percent of what ours is
in canada it's just 39 percent of what
ours is
other countries are still struggling
with the pandemic
but they're not doing as bad as we are
because they've got a government that's
actually been paying attention
and that means lives lost and that means
an economy that doesn't work
and just yesterday when asked if he'd do
anything differently
trump said not much really
not much nothing you can think of that
could have
helped some people keep their loved ones
alive
so joe's not going to screw up testing
he's not going to call scientists idiots
he's not going to host a super spreader
event at the white house
joe will get this pandemic under control
with a plan to make testing free and
widely available
to get a vaccine to every american cost
free
and to make sure our front-line heroes
never ask other countries
for the equipment they need
his plan will guarantee paid sick leave
for workers and parents affected by the
pandemic
and make sure that the small businesses
that hold our communities together
and employ millions of americans can
reopen safely
you know donald donald trump likes to
claim he built this economy
but america created 1.5 million more
jobs
in the last three years the obama biden
administration
then in the first three years of the
trump pence administration
how you figure that and that was before
he could blame the pandemic
now he did inherit the longest streak of
job growth in american history
but just like everything else he
inherited he messed it up
the economic damage he inflicted by
botching the pandemic response means he
will be the first president
since herbert hoover to actually lose
jobs
joe's got a plan to create 10 million
good
clean energy jobs as part of a historic
2 trillion dollar investment
to fight climate change to secure
environmental justice
and he'll pay he'll pay for it by
rolling back that tax cut for
billionaires
[Music]
and joe sees this moment not just as a
chance to get back to where we were
but to finally make long overdue changes
so that our economy actually makes life
a little easier for everybody the
waitress trying to raise her kid on her
own
the student trying to figure out how to
pay for next semester's classes
the shift worker who's always on the
edge of getting laid off
the cancer survivor who's worried about
her pre-existing conditions protections
being taken away let me tell you
something pennsylvania
this i know to be true joe and kamala
will
protect your health care and expand
medicare
and make insurance more affordable for
everybody you know
republicans love to say
right before an election that they'll
protect your pre-existing conditions
now joe and i actually protected your
policies to make sure people with
pre-existing conditions could get health
insurance and have coverage
we did it through something called the
affordable care act
aka obamacare
and republicans try to repeal
or undermine it more than 60 times
and when they've been asked about they
they keep on promising we're going to
have a great replacement
they said it's coming it's been coming
in two weeks for the last 10 years
where is it where is this great plan to
replace obamacare
they've had 10 years to do it there is
no plan
they've never had one instead they've
attacked
the affordable care act at every turn
driving up costs
driving up the uninsured now they're
trying to dismantle your care
in the supreme court as we speak as
quickly as they can
in the middle of a pandemic with nothing
but empty promises to take its place
it's shameful the idea that you would
take
health care away from people at the very
moment where people need it most
what is the logic of that
there is no logic
joe knows that a first the first job of
a president is to keep us safe
from all threats foreign domestic
or microscopic
when the daily intelligence briefings
flash warning signs about
a virus a president can't ignore him he
can't be awol
just like when russia puts bounties on
the heads of our soldiers in afghanistan
the commander-in-chief can't be missing
an action
i i can tell you this joe biden would
never call the men and women of our
military
suckers or losers
who does that he knows these
these heroes are somebody's children
somebody's spouse somebody's dad or mom
he understands that and he's going to
restore
our standing in the world because he
knows that america's true strength
comes from setting an example that the
world wants to follow
a nation that stands with democracy not
dictators
a nation that can mobilize and inspire
others
to overcome threats like climate change
and terrorism and
poverty and disease
and with joe and kamala at the helm
you're not going to have to think about
the crazy things they said every day
and that's worth a lot you're not going
to have to argue about them
every day
[Music]
it just won't be so exhausting you you
might be able to have a thanksgiving
dinner without having an argument
you'll be able to go about your lives
knowing that the president
is not going to retweet conspiracy
theories
about secret cabals running the world or
or
that navy seals didn't actually kill bin
laden
think about that the president the
united states
retweeted that imagine
what what
we're not going to have a president that
goes out of his way to insult anybody
who doesn't support him or or threaten
them with jail
that's not normal presidential behavior
we wouldn't tolerate it from a high
school principal
we wouldn't tolerate it from a coach we
wouldn't
tolerate it from a co-worker
we we wouldn't tolerate it in our own
family except for maybe crazy
uncle somewhere you know yeah he's
i mean we why would we expect
and ex accept this from the president of
the united states
and how why are folks making excuses for
that oh
well that's just that's just him no it's
no there are consequences
to these actions they embolden other
people
to be cruel and divisive
and racist and it frays the fabric of
our society
and it affects how our children see
things
and it affects the ways that our
families get along
it affects how the world looks at
america
that behavior matters
character matters
[Music]
[Applause]
and by the way while he's doing all that
it distracts all of us from the truly
destructive actions
that his appointees are doing
all across the government actions that
affect your lives
you know the environmental protection
agency that's supposed to protect our
air and our water is right now run by
an energy lobbyist that gives polluters
free rain to dump
unlimited poison into our air and water
the labor department that's supposed to
protect workers
and their rights right now it's run by
corporate lobbyists
who's declared war on workers guts
protections
to to keep essential folks safe during a
pandemic
makes it easier for big corporations to
shortchange them on their wages
the interior department that's supposed
to protect our public lands
and wild spaces our wildlife
and our wilderness and right now that's
run by an
oil lobbyist who's determined to sell
them to the highest bidder
you've got the education department
that's supposed to give every
kid a chance and that's run by a
billionaire who guts rules designed to
protect
students from getting ripped off by
for-profit colleges
and stiff-arm students looking for loan
relief in the middle of an economic
collapse
i mean the person who runs medicaid
right now
is doing their best to kick people off
of medicaid
instead of sign them up for medicaid
come on
when joe and kommel are in charge
they're not going to surround themselves
with hacks and lobbyists but they're
going to appoint
qualified public servants who actually
care about looking out for you
for your job for your family for your
health
for your security for your planet
and that more than anything is what
separates them from their opponents
they actually care about every american
including the ones that don't agree with
them
and they're going to fight for you
every day they care about you and they
care about this democracy
they believe in a democracy the right
to vote is sacred and that we shouldn't
be making people wait in line for 10
hours to cast their ballot
we should be making it easier for
everybody to vote
[Music]
they believe that no one especially
the president is above the law
they understand that protest
on behalf of social justice isn't
un-american
that's the most american thing there is
that's how this country was founded
protesting
injustice
they understand we don't threaten our
political opponents
threatening to throw them in jail just
because we disagree with them
they understand that our ability to work
together to solve big problems like a
pandemic
depends more than on just photo ops
it depends on actually learning the
facts
and following the science and not just
making stuff
up whenever it's convenient
we our democracy is not going to work if
the people
who are supposed to be our leaders
lie every day and just
make things up
i mean and we just become numb to it we
just become immune to it
every single day fact checkers can't
keep
up and and
and look this notion of
truthfulness and democracy and
and citizenship and and being
responsible
these aren't republican or democratic
principles they're american principles
they're what we're they're what we most
of us grew up
learning from our parents and our
grandparents
they're not white or black or latino or
asian
values their american values
human values and we need to reclaim them
we have to get those values back
at the center of our public life
and we can but but to do it
we've got to turn out like never before
we cannot leave any doubt in this
election
because you know he the president's
already said
if this is even close i'm going to just
make stuff up
he's already started to do it so we
can't have any doubt
we can't be complacent i don't care
about the polls
there were a whole bunch of polls last
time didn't work out
because a whole bunch of folks stayed at
home and got
lazy and complacent not this time
not in this election
not this side
listen listen i i understand why a lot
of americans
can get frustrated by government and can
feel
like it doesn't make a difference
even supporters of mine during my eight
years there were times where
stuff we wanted to get done didn't get
done and people said well you know
gosh if obama didn't get it done then
you know maybe it's just not
going to happen look government is not
going to solve every problem it's true
every elected official is going to make
some mistakes
this is a big complicated country and
the system's designed so that
change happens slowly it doesn't happen
overnight
and believe me i've got first-hand
experience
with the way republicans in congress
abuse the rule
easy for special interests to stop
progress
but we can make things better and we
should
we sure shouldn't be making things worse
a president by himself can't solve every
challenge
in a global economy but if we've got joe
biden and kamala harris in the white
house
and a house and senate that are focused
on working people
it can make a difference and get
millions of people the help they need
a president by himself can't eliminate
all racial bias
in our criminal justice system but if
we've got district attorneys and states
attorneys and sheriffs
and police chiefs focused on equality
and justice it can make things better
in pennsylvania you just gotta flip nine
seats in your state house
just five seats in your state senate to
give democrats control
and new life for policies they'll make a
real difference to working families
right now
it can make things better
and and it in the end pennsylvania
that's what voting is about
making things better not making things
perfect
but putting us on track so that
a generation from now we can look back
and say things got better
starting now and that's what's voting's
about
voting is about using the power we have
and pooling it together
to get a government that's more
concerned and more responsive
and more focused on you and your lives
and your children and your grandchildren
and future generations and the fact that
we don't get 100
of what we want right away is not a good
reason not to vote
it means we've got to vote and then get
some change
and then vote some more and then get
some more change
and then keep on voting until we get it
right
and we will never come close
to seeing what it would be like if
everybody voted when i hear people
saying well
i don't know you vote don't make a
difference we don't know because
usually no more than half the people who
could be voting vote
we get 50 55 percent of people voting
and then people say oh look you know not
enough change happened well
imagine what would happen if 60 voted
what about 70 percent
imagine january 20th when we swear
in a president and a vice president
who have a plan to get us out of this
mess
who believe in science and have a plan
to protect this planet for our kids
and who care about working americans and
have a plan
to help you start getting ahead and who
believe in racial equality
and gender equality and and believe in
not discriminating against people
because of their sexual orientation
and are willing to bring us closer to an
america
where no matter what we look like and
where we come from and
who we love and what our last name is if
we go out there and we work we can make
it
and we're part of an american family all
of that is possible
all of that is within our reach if we
vote
because let me tell you something
pennsylvania some people ask me
sometimes they say
man how have you been able to take these
last four years just watching all this
how do you how do you keep your spirits
up
and i tell them i say look for all the
times these last four years that we've
seen
our worst impulses revealed we've also
seen what our country can be at its best
we've seen folks of every age and
background
who packed city centers and airports in
town squares
just so families wouldn't be separated
so another classroom wouldn't get shot
up
so our kids wouldn't grow up on an
uninhabitable planet
we've seen americans of all races
joining together to declare
in the face of injustice that black
lives matter
no more but no less so that no child in
this country feels
the continuing sting of racism
we've seen folks
are our essential workers
our health care workers risking their
lives day in day out to save
somebody else's loved ones we've seen
people volunteer and contribute
to help those who are having an
especially difficult time that
right now that's true in pennsylvania
that's true all across the country
america is a good and decent place
but we've just seen so much noise
and nonsense that sometimes it's hard
for us to remember
philadelphia i'm asking you to remember
what this country can be what it's like
when we treat each other with respect
and dignity
what it's like when our elected
officials
actually behave responsibly i'm asking
you to believe
in joe's ability in kamala's ability
to lead this country out of these dark
times
and help us build it back better because
we can't
abandon those who are hurting right now
we can't abandon
the children who aren't getting the
education they need right now we can't
abandon
those protesters who inspired us we've
got to channel their activism into
action
we can't just imagine a better future
we've got to fight for it we've got to
out hustle the other side
we've got to work the other side we've
got to vote
like never before and leave no doubt
so make a plan right now for how you're
going to get involved and vote
do it as early as you can tell your
family tell your friends how they can
vote
don't stop with joe and kamala make sure
you vote all the way down the ticket
and if we pour all our efforts into
these 13 days
if we vote up and down the ticket like
never before
then we will not only elect joe biden
and kamala harris we will also leave no
doubt about what this country that we
love
stands for we will not leave any doubt
about who we are as a people and the
values
and ideals that we embrace
what lincoln called the better angels of
our nature
those are still in us we see him
operating every single day
we see him in neighborhoods we see him
in churches and synagogues and mosques
and temples
we see him in people helping out a
neighbor
we see him inside our own families we
see
that what is best in us is still there
but we've got to give it voice and we've
got to do it now
so let's get to work people let's bring
this home
i love you philadelphia honk if you're
fired up
honk if you're ready to go are you fired
up
are you ready to go are you fired up
are you ready to go
let's go make it happen i love you
philadelphia
thank you i love you
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
streets
[Music]
earthly
[Music]
is
[Music]